[Music]
34-7 at home and the Joker inside on the
skip dumps it down in the corner and
goes
Michael Porter Jr here's jokic posting
that puppet with the big cat cross the
lane Fade Away eight foot herbs
the Joker
[Applause]
what a date we have had day two of the
NBA Playoffs already a couple of Road
teams would win
meanwhile
yeah coach Finch talked about just the
maturity he had him when he was a rookie
how about the Finish there by Nicola
jokic now behind the back kicks it out
on the no-look pass and brown
what can Brown do for you
6-0 Minnesota run
yoke is
yeah we love Michael Malone one of our
favorites he's got that feistiness he's
got wade into his teeth look at York
that is basketball poetry big part of
the headline so far here in game two and
really in this series so far yokus back
to our cut look at that pass unreal
basketball like two that is off to
charts all right money thank you very
much
jokic working quickly
wow
[Applause]
she's getting back and forth
the jokic upstairs Gordon
and we saw that same play
the game
nuggets have hit six of their last Seven
Nations
the table for Gordon
trying to set up the double stagger from
Caldwell Polk give it the jokic bounce
it to Jeff Green wow now jokish against
rooted shoot over it
got him up with a pump fake company
Gordon Gordon lays it in boy jokic has a
sixth sense when he feels that second
Defender coming he sees the floor when
he spins the open watching Bill bear
thought he was going to shoot yeah yolk
is very weary also picking up another
foul
jokic reels in
scores it
more of that
the lead is five
under five minutes to go another's
trying to win on the road they've lost
five straight road playoff games
alley-oop scored now and Gordon hammers
it through
air Gordon
we'll get you into the corner Gordon
give and go to Joker
and Denver's showing some life
you can feel the nervousness in this
building everyone's standing jokic here
comes the reigning two-time MVP Fades
and
ends 11-2 Run for the Timberwolves
here's Conley lets it rip no rebound
jokic baseball pass
Murray with a layup
and Prince for Minnesota
jokic surveys underneath beautiful give
and go
those two together
Electric
to trust the past and trust their
offense against this defense again those
pesky non-joki minutes when he sits
that's been an issue for them not so
much in this series look at yogic
magnificent and a long rebound to Gordon
jokic
somehow left wide open
that was unwarranted maybe a technical
opportunity but Murray getting going
jokic dropping games
[Applause]
jokic
as we come up with a three-minute mark
[Applause]
what an atmosphere what is seen here in
Denver towns nearly the steal Gordon
gets it back and he puts it in
they'll get it to Murray 30 seconds
jokic did a little hesitation puts it in
and he's failed
and jokic putting him on his pitch
putting him on his back indeed of course
it was a little bit stagnant offensively
for Phoenix but nice set out of the
timeout for Bonnie Williams here's Matt
Diablo checks in the game joking she
goes right at him Durant on the health
defense Joker gets reported down in a
chance at three the hard way
Murray looking to push this is what they
want to do
pair jokic
poker on the pole
this is Bradley in the rebound by jokic
Suns right now look gassed
a little back door
coming with some heat they didn't get
him as incorporated into initiating
offense nearly as much in part because
of the turnovers and inability to
control that defensive backboard for a
yoga
both teams are playing defensively they
are not giving an inch
for a beautiful give it Go Marie
yo gets dropping dimes Joker just scored
their last seven six seconds
backing down biyombo to the Box Fades
Hayes unreal
let's see how long Monty Williams will
stay with Aiden on the floor jokic kicks
Casey kcp
crowded by eighteen six on the timer
Joker trying to create the space spins
off balance hook
unbelievable
guys he said he's got some sore losers
and they're showing that in the response
so far yeah a really strong response as
jokic carries and crowd getting
frustrated with DeAndre without a field
goal here in game three and it turns
into two on the other end Denver run
Murray has been terrific sets up jokic
he will fire and plop it home from three
from Durant in Booker
jokic gets fouled and floats it in a
chance for three for the two-time MVP
he's done an outstanding job of mixing
in the offensive players with the
defensive players Taryn
[Applause]
what a highlight you'll get you an
absurd pass and Porter the ridiculous
flush
again just trying to find some balance
to assist Booker and Duran Here Comes
yoga's banging bodies with ayton context
he's headed to the free throw line
career an incredible man was here with
him for five years
hard to believe he'll be gone
Murray feeds the post jokic sandwich
puts it down somehow able to get it to
drop
they can get stops get out in transition
and get easy scoring opportunities jokic
inside the Serbian sensation starting to
make him dizzy
[Applause]
jokic things in a Booker flicks it up
and it goes
[Applause]
inside
no one better with the ball in his hands
Here Comes Gordon spin drop step
beautifully done out of jokic content
and he's gonna shoot a free throw
suddenly that was the case game four and
certainly the case here in game five
you'll catch up top Gordon
Booker misses his first shot got knocked
to the ground thought he was fouled
Murray in transition
these are for your granny and there's
Porter with another basket first assist
for yokic he has struggled in the
postseason from three-point range
here's jokic nice pass Caldwell Pope
again he's also hit the deck a couple
times they were looking at that right
wrist by the way four turnovers by Kevin
Durant that matches how many field goals
he has in the game what a pass by jokic
and in one motion the high flying Gordon
stuffs it he shows no emotion just plays
[Music]
good job to dive there's that puts it up
and in see there's that floater and then
from the front Court people on the traps
and then rotating and taking away
potential layoffs
Reggie Jackson drills a three not as
much of a factor against Golden State
and they don't need him here in the
conference final
heel could spin finds Caldwell pulp
hunting
until you're able to catch a second win
but it's not it's not a fluke
the jokic goes inside lays it up and in
now when you played here did you notice
a difference in when the opponent came
in
a quick spin move inside for the dump
foreign
jokic
[Applause]
takes his time spins
looking falling away it's good
Lakers with 38 points here in the third
quarter
they cut it to 11.
the jokic just gets it off in time it's
up
of course they're comes in
it's from town
[Applause]
the unusual guys to see somebody call
out specifically about how they went at
them Thanksgiving goal Gordon the finish
on a beautiful pass from jokic
likes this matchup there's a double team
three sets three-pointer the jokic with
the rebound
ahead Murray all alone down the other
end
welcome back Brittany grind also
[Applause]
[Music]
and one
and not react to every call so
aggressively not just the players but
the coaches do and he said they like the
pace they're playing with when they get
stopped so he said we've got to make
that we gotta find a compliment for yoga
quarter to jokic
yoke is spinning shooting scoring and
the foul looking behind Porter
Michael Porter can't hit jokic another
rebound that's 14. Bruce Brown Victory
is offensively in his timely shots but
his outstanding defense against the
Joker
jokic spins count it and won in the
fourth quarter of game two in Denver
that's the same shot a cushion given
he takes it and makes it you know
answers back with a three-pointer the
color York it's 14 fourth quarter points
under three minutes remaining going
right back to the two-man game Murray
inside double team spins Flex it up and
in
Jamal Murray with a couple of buckets
here in the fourth
jokic off the dribble spins into the
paint kicks it out porter porter puts it
in Porter knocks it down and that makes
it
117-103 nice play by Russell Baseline
Drive Baseline drift
inside is Gordon and Gordon with six
points here on the first his scoring's
been down in this round
in the first second quarter Ari gets
inside back to yolkat shot clock winding
down Joker has to put it up high awesome
three oh he knocks it down
stepping backwards falling backwards and
the shot clock expiring
Gordon holding shot clock at six
[Applause]
finds Porter quarter a good look from
the corner got it again
as he would when he's going at the
basket from the post or isolating The
Joker shoots and scores rebound Porter
won't go Joker misses second one no good
and po-boy pup comes away back door Bobo
poke lay up this time he bangs it in on
a foul and the nuggets have their first
lead of the game Gordon guarded by
Schroeder Schroeder a good ball hound
[Applause]
inside a garden throws it down and the
foul yogic with another perfect pass and
a chance for a three-point play shot
clock is four
Joker Chester put it up falling away
puts it up
knocks it down his foot was on the line
a two-pointer what a shot
as a 24 second cup Anthony Davis on the
inbound Joker strides and puts it up and
in nuggets up by two Bernie for jokic
36 from three during these playoffs nice
Century pass jovich and Gordon with a
couple of dunks early on blocking shots
and competing defensively Michael Malone
said at timesheet was indifferent about
defense earlier in his career nice entry
pass
and Murray able to knock it in
three second different shot clock and
game clock Brown Caldwell Polk fires up
a three
rebound seller knocked away nice feed
and Joker spanks it in autobio like
jokic is a point Center terrific dish
here comes a double team spins away
finds Brown wide open Bruce Brown from
downtown there's Jamal Murray and the
Nuggets off to a good start Mike
Greenberg Michael wilbon Jalen Rose zero
the building at Paul arena in Denver
they do have a foul to give nice pass
from Murray The Joker flips it up and in
I'm still looking for a mentor from this
Cruise
Murray up top jokes shot clock winding
down knocks down the lokich
thank you
spinning backs in out of aisle pokes it
away four to shoot Joker's Falling Away
puts it in
you have to try to make him score you
mentioned that about jokes in the last
game Mark you'll catch y'all gorgeous
pass and Gordon that's what Gordon did
in the first quarter of game off
full court pressure for Caleb Martin
again as Lisa Salters reported to top
Martin
question before the game I've been
feeling sick last couple of days
jokic gets it back goes down Elaine
stops blocked by adebayo joking on the
second effort throws it up and in 11
points four assists three rebounds for
Butler much more aggressive
then in game one yolkitz touched past
the garden
that's ridiculous
the Elkins we're gonna take Zeller backs
down backs down draws the foul shotgun
and one
he had his mind made up that time and a
chance for a three-point play quarter
for the Joker
[Applause]
[Music]
deflected stolen by Brown Here Comes
jokic bringing it up the floor going
Coast to Coast layup it's good
his three-pointer
[Applause]
[Music]
Joker's calling for the ball against
Kevin Love spins flips it up and in and
that's a great job sprinting the floor
and sailing getting real estate in the
middle of the paint Miami's physicality
is having an impact here as they go into
the zone
Brown throws it down
[Applause]
now out of battle comes out jokes throws
it up and Gordon kind of tips it in with
his fingertips another beautiful pass
from jokic
New York it's spinning love picks him up
off one foot that's good Eric's poster
was saved even on these wild shots he
expects it to go in
[Music]
Ari's back up miocic fakes spins the
pirouette
and the bucket is good 32 points 20
rebounds 10 assists shows you the
Brilliance of joke how many big guys are
directing the traffic in that situation
gets it kicks it out Caldwell pulp is
wide open connects on a three they're
much more physical
[Music]
keeping the ball out of the paint and on
the shot blocking out the Joker from way
downtown Butler great defense for Safari
to pass
maybe it's because the ball was in the
front Court
[Applause]
three
Aaron Gordon
the fake the drive the left-handed shot
is good
[Music]
[Applause]
Murray gets his back double team yoga
goal a time of the world answers with
another three that's his third
three-pointer I knew could have been the
MVP of the Eastern Conference Finals the
slow start to these finals but he's got
nine here tonight
Murray the Elkins throws it inside to
Gordon oh another great touch pass and
Gord with a beautiful finish
the foul by the way was on jokic who
still hasn't taken a shot
that ends right now
[Applause]
[Music]
Brown in the game the rookie for the
Nuggets you all catch nice feed and
green banks at home
at a bioguard in jokic
Elkins backing in and backing in Double
T gets up the shot because pullers his
way through the double demon scores
Lowry down sorry and jokic play catch
Vincent on him out of Bio lurking ball
poked away jokic gets it back puts it up
and in and a foul
and more putting Joker in the pickle
action if I only
Pope the rebound off the Miss free throw
Mario left the glass won't go tipped in
by
Bruce Brown
[Applause]
s against Alabama tough shot pulling
away still knocks it down
Murray de Gordon
Baldwin Pope finds Joker jokic in the
paint drops it in he's got 26 it's a
seven point lead Murray pulls back
finds jokic marking on him joking
strides down a lane layup is good
nuggets back up by one
[Applause]
it's over
at last the long wait is over after 47
years the Denver Nuggets can finally
call themselves NBA champions